I've been thinking and remembering and
recalling in the last few days movies
that I've seen at different times and
when I was a kid and when I say a kid I
don't mean a teenager even what we would
call a tween I mean like you know from
four up to 10 or so a lot of the movies
that we saw were not in movie theaters
themselves they were in what we call
drive-in movie theaters where you would
actually like drive your car in there
they become I guess they they first
started in the 1930s and they became
really popular in the 50s and 60s and
they kept building them and doing a
little research on this because I was
trying to figure out well what movie
theater did we actually go to it looks
like Wisconsin got into the game a
little bit later in the 60s and 70s and
I I was growing up as a kid in the 70s
we lived officially in the township of
Dallas field in a subdivision that took
a long time to fill up that used to be
old Prairie and woods called the hills
of Dolla field just just north of the
village of Wales where I went to
elementary school and you know we
actually would do a lot of things in in
Wales and so we lived really far out in
the sticks just to give you an idea
about that and I think I may have
mentioned this in other stories
for a long time there were almost no
restaurants around us we were living out
in the middle of nowhere
I know we could go into Dallas field and
there were a few restaurants there on
the way on Highway 83 there was a a
drive-in
um what would you call it like you know
it was called dog and suds and so that
tells you what they had uh you know hot
dogs and hamburgers I guess and stuff
like that and then root beer I think it
still exists you can still find dog and
suds root beer and you pull your car up
and then they you know they'd hook this
thing onto the window and you'd give
your order and they'd come out with your
your food and you'd eat it in your car
right there was no inside to it
um well the the drive-in movie theaters
were like that too and I don't remember
exactly which one we went to I just
remember it was probably like a half
hour drive to get there so it might have
been the one that was further west on
Highway 18
it might have been the one that was on
the east side of Waukesha for all I know
which would have equally been about the
same distance off of Highway 59 but this
is kind of a big thing you know you
would you'd pile into your car and for
us it was you know my dad and my mom and
then me and my sister and you know front
seats at that time were not generally
bucket seats except in like sports cars
it was like a big bench seat and
everyone would sit there and you know
you'd bring like blankets and pillows
and actually we would go in our pajamas
because it was at night we would
typically fall asleep so you know we'd
drive out there and I think we'd bring
like some you know some water and some
sodas or something like that maybe maybe
some beers for my mom and dad I don't I
don't really know and then you could
like you could order food right but you
drive up and then you would get this
speaker
the outward clip onto your your window
and you know when you think about it the
sound quality could not have been
particularly good it's all coming
through this little speaker maybe they
were also projecting it you know on
Broad speakers
um but you know you couldn't you
couldn't hear really great but yeah this
gigantic movie screen and you would look
through your windshield or you might
actually even get out of the car and sit
on the car if it was warm enough and you
just watch it right everybody together
hanging out and there'd be you know like
older people in their cars and families
like us and our cars and tons of
teenagers and 20-somethings probably not
paying much attention to the movie but
like making out or getting it on or
stuff like that but we would be there
and we would uh we'd watch the movie
and you could hear the people around you
sometimes like if it was a very dramatic
part of the movie
I you know I'm doing that kind of thing
people would also clap at the end of the
movies as well and
um oftentimes it'd be like a double
header like they'd play one movie and
then they'd play another or they'd play
some cartoons before the movie and then
they'd they'd play the movie and I only
remember I know we went to a whole bunch
of these right I only actually remember
two movies particularly well
from that uh theater wherever it
happened to be
one of them was called Sinbad and the
eye of the tiger
and this was like an adventure movie
based very very Loosely on the character
Sinbad from the Arabian Knights and you
know it's um I think if we were to watch
it now we'd be like holy crap the
special effects on that were were pretty
awful had a lot of like what we now call
claymation things you know he's fighting
like a saber-toothed tiger and you know
it would be like stop-motion photography
um what else did he he fight a whole
bunch of different Monsters of of
different sorts and I don't really
remember much of the plot I just
remember Sinbad fighting all of these
these uh monsters and going on sea
voyages and I thought it was really
super cool
the other movie that I remember actually
seeing in the theater and we might have
actually seen a sequel to Sinbad in the
the drive-in theater the other movie I
remember seeing was
um
the Smokey and the Bandit I almost said
Cannonball run but no it was Smokey and
the Bandit and if you don't know that
movie it is what's the genre of it I
guess you know vehicle movies
um there were quite a few that were
quite popular at the time there was
Convoy and basically
um if I remember what's going on right
Burt Reynolds has got a super fast car
and all the cops are trying to chase him
meanwhile his buddy is I think hauling
beer that's illegal from one state to
the other or something like that and
anyway he's he's uh uh the Bandit I
think and Smokey is of course the cops
right because he used to communicate
with CBS right oh Smokey's down down the
road from us right and again I don't
remember an awful lot of the plot from
it I just remember there was a lot of
like car chases and funny moments and
probably jokes that I didn't quite get
but my parents were laughing at and
that's what you know that's what a lot
of movies were like you know
I do remember also going to see some
Sci-Fi movies as a matter of fact now
that I recall
I also did see
um Star Trek 2
The Wrath of Khan
in a different drive-in movie and this
was when I was a tween with my uh at
that time Aunt Bib and soon to be Uncle
Scott that was the summer that actually
my dad died and I was staying in Indiana
the entire summer and you know drive-in
movies were really big same sort of deal
you pull up you get your speaker maybe
you walk somewhere and get some popcorn
or sodas or hot dogs or whatever you
know Candy whatever it's gonna be and
that's that's what we typically did you
know there'd be like gravel everywhere
um because you you know you were at a
drive-in theater and the parking was on
gravel so I remember like walking on the
gravel and like going with my dad to
pick up popcorn for all of us and you
know some some drinks or stuff like that
and then you know if you had to go to
the bathroom uh you would you would get
out and walk over to the bathroom and it
was kind of a cool app atmosphere it's
very different than going to an indoor
theater where you know you've got your
ticket and you pay for it and then you
walk in and somebody takes your ticket
and then they're like go over there you
know you go to the drink and food
counter and you get your stuff and you
walk to your seat and then you know put
your soda and the cup holder and you got
your popcorn in your lap or your you
know Twizzlers or Jujubes or whatever it
happens to be that you're going to eat
right and then everyone you know it's
dark in there and uh you know first the
previews come on and all this sort of
stuff and
so the Outdoor Theater was much more of
a communal thing I mean you can go with
your family to a regular theater and
you're all sitting in the same seats
right but this was like you're literally
in the same vehicle and it was I just
remember it being a lot of fun I I
really enjoyed it and I think that you
know sometimes it could be a little
chilly so you'd have like a blanket and
you know uh you might fall asleep during
the movie or something like that if it
was pretty late certainly we'd fall
asleep on the car ride back home and it
was a really fun enjoyable thing for me
as a kid that um I I don't think we did
an awful lot of later on you know it
just kind of dropped out and going to
regular movie theaters became the way
things were done or we'd watch things
watch movies as it became available on
TV through cable so it was it was in a
certain sense a
not necessarily a product of its time
because it was a product of an earlier
time that had gotten carried forward but
it was
something that you did in the 70s much
more than you would in the 80s or the
90s apparently during covid drive-in
theaters experienced a kind of
Renaissance because you could sit in
your car and not be sitting next to
somebody else who might have kovid in
the movie theater so you know those that
were still around started doing uh
Better Business and there were even like
impromptu drive-in theaters where they
would just find like a building to
project uh movies onto and everyone
would get together that way or you do it
in a park or something kind of cool like
that but this was like a regular thing
and it was mostly for us
something that we did in the summer
I don't think we did it too far into the
fall because it you know would start to
get really cold right and you've got
your window open but I think there were
some drive-in theaters that would
actually run like almost year round even
here in in Wisconsin we just didn't
typically go to them but you know to
bring this to a close this is a a really
Pleasant memory for me thinking about
how we would get together as a family
and sometimes I remember this as well
sometimes we'd get together with a
couple families and each would like have
their own car and you'd like arrange
yeah we're going to be there at seven
o'clock you know as the sun is starting
to to go down and we're all going to
hang out together we'll park next to
each other right uh maybe you know
people will swap from car to car like
put all the kids in this car and then
the adults can be in this car or
something like that and it was just such
a fun thing to do and I'm I'm really
glad that
um you know my childhood included that
it was also pretty cheap you know which
I think that was an attraction for my
parents who were making good money but
you know both came from Kind of Blue
Collar families so they and it was the
70s too so you know you saved your money
for as much as you could
um so that's that's basically all there
is to that story I thought I would share
this uh interesting experience that I
was fortunate enough to have with you if
you get a chance to go to a drive-in
movie theater
um you know maybe check it out there's
quite a few of them out there and still
existing in the wild uh they've actually
created a few new ones I know here in
Wisconsin
um and I'm sure there there's plenty all
over the place in other parts of the
states and other countries as well
um and you know it could be kind of a
fun thing to do different than the other
Much More
formulaic Much More structured Movie
experience that we have with our
theaters in the present